When we created the main
restaurants page,
we executed a query to get all of
the restaurants in the database.
I will use the ID number of each
restaurant entry in order to
find a specific restaurant to update.
Let's go ahead and
replace that hashtag with the restaurant
ID number, and then a backslash, and
the word edit to indicate a new path
where we will edit our menu entries.
I will now create another if statement
that looks for /edit in my URL.
Since I chose to edit
restaurants by their ID,
I need to find a way to grab
that ID number out of the URL.
The split command in Python
comes in handy here and
returns an array of strings
separated by the backslash.
I figured out that the third value
of this array contains my ID number.
So with this 2 here,
I'm grabbing the third element
of this zero indexed array.
I then do a restaurant query to
grab the restaurant entry equal to
the ID in the URL.
If I find that query, then I generate
a response and begin to render the page.
I can create a form with one field for
the new restaurant name.
Let's create a post method,
and pass in the path for
the /restaurants/ID/edit, passing in
the ID of the restaurant I want to edit.
I also pre-filled this field with
the current name of the restaurant.
I close all my tags and
add this output string to the wfile.
Now, let's write up the post
response for our edit form.
Some of this code might be
starting to look pretty familiar.
After making another if statement,
we grab the input from our form again.
Then we perform the query to find
the object with the matching ID.
We reset the name field to
the entry we created in the form,
then add to the session and commit.
I then added a redirect to bring
us back to our restaurants page
after the code has been executed.
This was a lot of code to write.
So let's save and rerun our
server again to see if it worked.
If I rename Panda Garden to
The New Panda Garden, look!
It's been updated in the database and
in our restaurants page.
The source code for objective four is
also available in the instructor notes.